شهد مخيم اللاجئين الفلسطينيين القديم وشاتيلا كل شيء
للصغار، إنه مجرد بداية لحياة
مكتظة بأكثر من 14000
شخص في ساحة A4 Mile، يقع
مخيم اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في
بيروت على بعد مئات الأميال من غزة
ولكن بالنسبة للعديد من الناس  هنا، التي عاشت
حروبًا سابقة، تبدو الحرب في غزة
قريبة جدًا، جاءت نادرة جوهر البالغة من العمر 77 عامًا إلى هنا
وهي طفلة من منزلها في ما كان يُعرف آنذاك
بفلسطين، وقد شاهدتها من قريب وبعيد حربًا
بعد حرب، لكنها لا تزال مصدومة من
الصور من
غزة، الألم الذي تشعر به تجاه كل
[الموسيقى]
الأبرياء ندوب القس التي
يمكن
رؤيتها في سبتمبر 1982،
وقف الجيش الإسرائيلي متفرجًا بينما
ذبح حلفاؤه المسيحيون اللبنانيون أكثر من
ألف مدني فلسطيني ولبناني
هنا وفي
منطقة صبرا المجاورة تتلاشى  الملصقات تلصق على
الجدران وجوه الأبطال السابقين الذين
وعدوا بالكثير ولكن لم يتمكنوا من تقديم الكثير
للناس
هنا. سكان المخيم يتتبعون جذورهم
إلى مدينة يافا، وانتهى بهم الأمر هنا
بعد ما أسموه النكبة، "
الكارثة" عندما فر أكثر من
700,000 فلسطيني أو  تم طردهم
من منازلهم عندما تأسست إسرائيل،
المشاهد من غزة
تذكرنا بشكل مؤلم بالماضي،
يخشى صاحب المتجر السابق محمد عفيفي أن يتكرر الأمر،
العيون هنا مفتوحة ولكن لا يمكنهم إلا
المشاهدة من بعيد بن ويدمان سي إن إن مخيم شاتيلا للاجئين